Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday, November 13th, 2017.
What's going on? How I,
yeah, what's going on?
I am in New York City, both boom, boom.
Buttered oda doubt to dote. Um, oh,
it's actually Hollywood with the fuck
am I thinking? It's not a New York Song,
right?
Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam,
Bam,
Bam.
Did it. It did it. That's Hollywood right?
That's in New York side.
Starts spread in the nose.
Right? I don't fucking know.
I'm all over the map here. Um,
I'm winding down this trip. I just
wrapped up my acting gig on front runner.
Uh, I want to thank everybody that,
that allowed me to be on that movie.
I had such a great time. I met so many
great people on that shoot. And, uh,
the last night of the shoot,
I actually got to do a scene with
the star of the movie. He was
Jackman.
And um,
I can't even tell you how great
that experience was. He might,
he might be the not one of the nicest
guys I've ever met in my life. Uh,
totally cool. Big Guy too. He's like
six, four or something. Big Guy.
Totally cool. Nicest fucking dude ever.
Then you start doing the scene right.
And it's,
his character in the scene was getting,
was getting mad and
frustrated with us dude.
And he went into that wolverine thing a
little bit. I was just like, Jesus Christ,
I will not fuck with this guy.
Just an amazing,
amazing actor.
And uh, I was the coolest
thing. Like on the last night,
we had like two things to shoot,
like one quick thing in a car and then
the whole rest of the thing was, uh,
us, you know, like me and two
other actors and Hugh Jackman.
And it was just like, it was a,
yeah, we shot that the whole night.
And it was one of those
things where he's like,
I wouldn't really care if we continued
shooting this scene tomorrow.
I'm having so much fun. You know
what I found out? I actually,
I like to run when I act.
This scene involves me running into
running before I delivered the,
uh,
my lines or whatever.
And I found that I really liked that
and I was just like, wow, no wonder.
I always like William
Shatner and Tj Hooker.
I know I've talked about this before,
but if you ever watch TJ hooker,
I don't think in the history
of television they ever,
they ever made an actor run farther than
they made William Shatner who's well
into his 50s by then they would just have
like this the master shot of the scene
and I want to get all Hollywood here
run yet, but the master is just,
when you go to shoot this
scene is you're just,
it's a wide shot and you're capturing
every character in it or you're
establishing the place, the
setting. I have no fucking idea.
I think that's what it is.
Right. They would just,
they would just be standing
on the other side of a wharf,
a runway like Williams shot and he chased
after planes and they would just start
and he would come running around the
corner and he would always be like look 70
yards away and they'd be playing this
fucking music with the Bongos in the
background and you would watch him just
full speed running a man in his 50s all
right. And this is like
the 80 so no guys stretched
unless you were on like you know you
had to be like in the Olympics and even
then if you watch like the old NFL films,
the way that they would stretch,
you know what I mean? They weren't
doing like any just sort of you know,
doing a forward bend, none of that
Yoga Shit. It was like touch your toes,
touch your hips,
touching shoulders,
do a jumping jack come back down
or whatever the fuck they would do,
what to treat for that type of stuff.
I'm running and cop shoes,
full speed for a good 80 yards.
This is actually a great youtube video
that I think I posted before of we have
of Tj hooker running. Um, so anyways,
I had the, uh, I had the best time and uh,
did the perfect amount of time on the
movie cause right when it ended I came
right here to New York and then I'm
going to go back and the rest of my year,
other than like two road gigs,
I am done.
And I'm going to get to spend this
ridiculous amount of quality time with my
wife and daughter and I can't wait.
I'm totally getting into the
Christmas spirit this year.
Not to the point of
sacrificing thanksgiving. Um,
you know,
I don't know,
I might even put up a couple of little
like cut up turkeys in my house.
I hate out thanksgiving, just gets
passed over. You know what I mean?
Gets passed over like a a,
I dunno like a person that should
have got the job but didn't write a,
but I'm totally getting into it and I am,
I'm still so ba was it,
he was 84 days on
Thursday. So 85, 86, 87 88.
Eric Lindros 88 Lynn Swann.
I wasn't he 88. Yeah. Um,
88 days. Not boozing. And uh, I think
I'm going to go for the hundred.
I don't know. You know, I
think I will be, let's see,
I'll be 91 on Thursday
a week from Thursday.
It'll be 98 and then there'll
be thanksgiving. And what,
I'm not going to have a little
brandy in my eggnog there.
A big with the brandy and
the egg Nog you know? Um,
that's what I would have added to the
great opie and Anthony bit the Eggnog.
OPA Anthony Little Jimmy. Right? You think
those guys love to get back together?
Do like a reunion tour.
They should have like a one off.
You don't need like a toy. You don't
like the police got back together.
They should do that with great radio shows
where everybody eventually, you know,
just got sick of each other
and went the other way.
But the fans are still sitting there
like, come on man, just to one more tour,
man. They should all
get together. You know,
I think it will have guns and
roses can get back together.
Right.
Um,
I know, fucking know.
Anyways, plowing ahead of you.
I'm totally going to get
into the holidays. Uh,
okay.
And I dunno, I dunno about the drinking
thing. I think I'm done for a while.
Like I said, I want to go staying in
my fifties. I'm turning 50 in June
and um,
I want to make sure, uh, I dunno,
that's a critical fucking decade,
right?
That's that one. They make, you know,
people like fucking die in their 50s.
So I get them.
That's when people just start dying.
I mean, people, I've, I've gotten,
I've already lost, like I've lost count
how many fucking friends I actually,
I have a list on my phone,
so I don't forget all the comics
that I've known that have died.
Um, by the way, all men,
all men out of the 25,
they're all meant,
so all these women out there like you
don't understand how difficult it is to be
a woman. It's like, lady, I got
25 dead friends. They're all guys.
Okay,
I don't know what the fuck is going
on with us, but whatever you guys are,
there's something that you guys,
something in your life is easier.
I know in this age of feminism
where it just has to be,
everything is so fucking much harder
for a woman. There is one easy thing,
one easier thing for a woman and it really
is the most important thing and that
is staying alive.
I wouldn't fuck is my phone.
I got them all like I got and I'm,
I'm, I'm probably going to
forget a few people. All right,
let's see here.
These are all the fucking people
did I knew that had gone here.
All right. It all started with Mitch
Hedberg in like March I think at 2005.
Mitch Hedberg, Freddy Soto, Mitch
Malanie, Robert Schimmel, Bernie Mac,
Dave Fitzgerald, Kevin Knox,
Bob Side Bell, Bob Lazaruth,
rich size slur auto from auto and
George Greg Giraldo, Patrice O'Neal,
Todd Lynn, Sam Brown, Charlie Murphy,
Scott Kennedy, John Pinette, Richard Jeni,
Mike [inaudible], Fano,
Ralphie may and peak coming.
Those are all the people that I knew
really well or worked with as a comedian
then have all died since 2005 separate
day. Fitzgerald. He died earlier.
He doesn't like 2001. It
was a Boston karmic. Um,
and I probably forgot a few people,
you know, club owners,
Manny Dorman, Lucian Hole.
And then I have like let's high school
kids that I went to school with. One, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven, eight. All guys.
Okay.
Fucking unbelievable.
He just don't understand sometimes
what it's like to be, I know,
I absolutely,
I'm sure it's fucking a much more
difficult than a lot of ways,
but I'll tell you that the most
important way, staying alive,
that's not, forget that. Um, anyways, uh,
so I did the, uh, the
new west side comedy club
and it was just the perfect layout.
And I also love to,
it's right around the corner from
the, uh, the beacon theater. So, uh,
I've gotten to play,
there were a couple of times,
but what I also love is if I was
a young competing starting out,
it's really like this motivational thing
where you walk out and then you walk
around the corner and there's the beacon
theater and you can kind of be thinking,
you know, Sunday, maybe I'll
be able to play that place.
That's the type of shit
that used to get me. Um,
yeah,
used to get me motivated
when I was starting out,
although I don't know
about playing theaters.
I think it was just seeing Caroline's
comedy club because when I was starting
out, like nobody played theaters.
It was like Cosby played theaters.
George Carlin like you had
to be like a legend. Um,
Joan Rivers,
um,
those people played like theaters
and um,
you know, for most comedians when
I started, I think it was, um,
the dream was to just sell out clubs.
The dream was to sell out clubs and
to get a Sitcom built around your act.
Uh,
that was the dream.
And then somewhere along the line it's
switched and a lot of people talk about,
you know,
social media and Blah Blah and all that.
I think the biggest thing that is created,
one of the big things that people
forget as far as like how all of these
comedians now are,
are big enough of a draw to play theaters.
I think one of the best
things that happened for
comedians that nobody brings up
is Napster.
An online file sharing air quote,
sharing of music,
which was really stealing
music that completely destroyed
the music business and
their ability to make stars.
Um,
you remember virgin records but you would
go in there and they had that little
CD listening thing and they had like
the top 10 or the top 20 cds and they'd
always be like a new band in there.
It's like they were feeding,
you know,
bringing new people in.
And once Napster came out and then there
was the live wire and all of that shit
and then iTunes and all of
that, what happened was, um, oh,
am I gonna use this term?
There was an the development of new,
like when you look at like the amount
of bands that broke through and like the
last 10 years that was suddenly
able to sell out arenas.
It's like a handful of bands
or people like lady Gaga,
Bruno Mars was at 21 pilots is very few
that got that big.
Um, at least not as much
as uh, as they used to.
I feel my might be completely wrong on
this, but if I'm, if I'm not mistaken,
there was like,
like the MTV music or had like the five,
the same five artists for a long time.
We're with a few new ones but like,
like Jay z Kanye and like, I dunno,
I'm not so good with all the,
all the youngest people stuff,
but they stuck around forever at those
music awards because there was not these
new people coming in.
MMM.
Usually for somebody to stick around
in a music award for over 10 years.
I feel like there was only a
couple of bands that could do it,
but they had to keep those people from
10 years previous cause they all got
knocked out.
And then I'm going to get to a point here.
So everything became a quick
little bullshit. I don't
want to pay for it online.
And I think in everybody went online,
either wanted to fucking uh,
watch someone do something incredible
on a skateboard, some x games,
shit. Or you wanted to watch people
fail and you wanted to laugh.
And I feel like standup comedy fit
into that set up punch, set up, punch.
It was quick. They made you
laugh, you fucking moved on.
And then I think comedians slid into
all of these theater gigs that were,
all of these bands would have been
playing. I'm not talking arenas,
I just mean like, like theaters. I
might be wrong on that one, but I think,
um, if you look at the graph
as music business imploded,
comedy went through the fucking roof.
Then also with technology,
I'll comics comics could just
keep putting out these specials.
And then Netflix was another big thing.
But everybody talks about that.
But nobody seems, I don't know.
I think the music business,
I'm completely imploding
also helped out stand up.
It created a void. Um, I don't know.
You liked it and you're like me
discussing the fee, the INS and outs
of ticket sales and standup comedy.
So anyways, so I was working at the,
uh, west side comedy
club. You got to go there.
Some old friends of mine opened
the place up. That's why I did it.
I had the best time. And what was
really cool is it mostly, you know,
podcasts listeners,
so I could say whatever the fuck I
thought essentially in these times,
you know what I mean? Everything
that's going on, you know,
I heard like those fucking,
okay.
People were going down to the comedy
cellar and then writing down what other
comics were saying about Louis Ck and
all of that type of stuff was just,
it's just so fucking, it's
such a crazy time. Right. Um,
and, uh, you know, I dunno,
I love Louis C K and that
was really obviously just
at fucking hard thing to see
happen to somebody. And he was definitely
100% wrong. I'll just say this,
he was 100% wrong.
He did own up to it and I think
he will definitely be back.
Um,
I will say that,
and I also knew a couple of the
women that he did the shit too.
And I just felt bad for everybody.
It's just fucking terrible. And uh,
I dunno. I Dunno. I Dunno. What
else do you see you say about it?
I feel like I'm in a divorce where,
you know, both the mom and the dad.
You need just, you got to like
pick a fucking side here. Uh,
you know, I dunno all, I think that
just this new thing though is like,
like the level of witch hunt that
happened when the Louis think came out.
Like the amount of fucking people
that they went after was just fucking,
it was like six degrees of Louise Dick,
you know,
to the point that even the fucking
Huffington post was even trying to like,
you know,
list people that clients have the
same manager that he had and stuff.
Food by the way, is one of the
great people I've ever met in life.
I stand by my fucking manager
and I'm never firing the guy.
I've been with this guy since 2006 date.
Becky's one of the great people that I've
met in this business. I love that guy.
It's still have him over
my house for fucking dinner
watching everybody just, Oh,
I think I remembered this
happening 15 fucking years ago.
And then watching everybody tried
to burn down this guy's life.
It's just fucking predicts people. This
is America. You remember due process,
like the whole thing, it's
just like, it's fucking insane.
I wouldn't be surprised
if they don't have to.
Louis Ck is mailman man saying if you
deliver his mail yet part of the problem,
um,
you know,
and it doesn't seem to be like
there's any sort of like, you know,
when the judicial system where
there's like if you steal a bike,
you get this sentence. If you rob a
bank, you get this. If you kill somebody,
if you kill a whole bunch of people all
the way up to the death penalty. Yeah.
This kind of seems like it's become,
um,
it doesn't make a difference if it's
sexual misconduct all the way to sexual
assault slash rape,
you know,
you're getting the exact same,
uh,
like level of punishment. Um,
so that's only my question.
Okay. Out of all of this
because he was definitely wrong.
Obviously I'm, that means is all
obvious shit that I'm saying. But, uh,
does the punishment match
the crime because you know,
sexual misconduct when you
talk about sexual misconduct?
Like I, I don't, I would,
I don't know how many podcast I would
have to do to tell you all the stories of
sexual misconduct,
but just women as a standup comedian
who used to go out after his shows,
selling his posters
all and taking pictures
with, to just the fucking
women. Okay. And I'll tell you,
it was never any of the young ones.
It was always these
middle age fucking women.
Couple of glasses of red wine.
Oh God.
And they'd come at you with their vulva
boom energy and you'd be like, oh no,
here we go. You know, that's my advice.
Young male comics out there,
young female comics is plenty of
information out there for you now about
watching out for creepy guys.
But I don't think there's anything
out there for young male comics.
I will tell you this,
okay.
If you're going to go out and meet a
crowd afterwards, when middle aged women,
you can tell they've had too much wine
beyond the fact that they're sort of
teetering on their high heels shoes with
their old feet sticking out of them,
just looked for the great teeth.
All right.
And a little bit too much
makeup and then that, you know,
they got the girls out a little bit.
Just fucking watch yourself. Okay.
Cause that's the,
uh,
that's the old cheerleader who is not
aging well and is freaking out that guys
don't find her attractive anymore.
And I'm telling you,
they're going to come up to you Eric,
you know,
Covey of junk.
That's all I'm going to say.
Dude.
I hit a woman,
licked my neck one time and I'll tell
you worst than the touch of her tongue,
her old ass, disgusting wine
breath tongue on my fucking neck.
Worse than that was, I felt her
breath right before the eagle landed.
I will, uh Oh gee, oh and
forget about gay guys.
Jesus Christ. I got to do another
half podcast on that one. We've,
we're just talking about
sexual misconduct. Um,
I always wanted to rub your chest.
The fuck did you just do
I remember what time it is. The thing
about a guy when it happens to a guy,
it's just funny just for the simple
fact that, you know, generally speaking,
you can overpower whoever the
fuck is coming at you. I'm not a,
I'm not a little boy,
so I get why nobody gives a
shit when this happens to a guy.
I get it.
Um,
I remember I was dating this absolutely
lovely woman, beautiful woman.
She danced on Broadway.
She was such a sweet town.
I loved him to death and I completely
fucked it up cause I was an angry young
man. So I'm sorry to her. Right.
So she was dancing in this
thing called Broadway bears,
which was like,
they used to do this thing to raise money.
It was like a burlesque show. So it
wasn't like this creepy titty bar thing.
It was just, uh, you know, if
you ever go to a burlesque show,
which my wife took me to one to see
that Dita von Teese. I was just like,
are you fucking kidding me? She's going
to take me down here to go to go see,
basically go to a rated PG 13 strip club.
I have the coolest wife ever.
And then I got down there and I think I
was the only straight guy there and it
was like mostly gay guys, right?
And uh, that's what this
Broadway bears thing was. It,
it wasn't like the creepy who'd is five?
So it's actually better if
there's a bunch of gay dude sick.
Cause I always did that whole,
I feel like Hooters strip clubs,
titty bars and all that shit.
It's just like,
that's something that's like fascinating
when you're like in your 20s I think.
And then somewhere, you
know, if you're progressing,
if you're maturing at some
point it just becomes gross.
Or at the very least like this
is fucking stupid. You know,
I want to go out and get laid.
I'm going to sit here looking at naked
women who aren't going to fuck me.
You know, this is stupid
while losing a ton of money,
paying for watered down drinks went,
now I don't want to eat in here.
You were in the sex industry, get away
from me. I want to order some food. Right?
So I go down to this Broadway
bears thing right? And, uh,
you know,
there's all these fucking lyrics,
there's all these smoking hot
women doing their dances and stuff.
And then there's all these shredded dudes.
So all the gay guys are
going nuts about the dude's.
And I'm looking at all these women
going like, oh my God. Right.
Fucking dance or legs. They were
incredible. Right? Oh, by the way,
they also were really talented.
All right,
so the fucking show ends.
Okay.
And I'm waiting for my girlfriend at the
time to come out and this fucking out
of nowhere, this guy came up and just
smack me on the ass. And it wasn't like,
like, it was like if you were
playing football, it was good game,
but at that place it was, it, this guy
wanted to fucking hook up me. Dude,
he hit me so hard,
like I almost fucking got whiplash and
I fucking turned around and I can't say
what I said to the guy.
Um,
but I made it clear to him that I
wasn't gay and I'll never forget,
he just like put his hands
up and was like backing away.
Yeah.
Edelman where he put his hands up
the dude at these fucking guns.
And I was just like, you know, I don't
know what this guy's thinking right now,
but if he wanted to do something,
I don't know if there's anything I
could do about it and never forget is,
is big hairy gay arms just going,
Oh, oh, I'm sorry. I just fucking,
no, you didn't even talk like that.
I'm doing like the hacky gave voice.
He had just like a regular dude voice.
And um,
I'll do, I got a zillion of those
fucking zillion of those fucking stories.
If we're talking sexual misconduct
here. And um, and you know,
it's funny is the reason I stopped going
out after my shows wasn't all of those
fucking witches of Eastwick drunk bitches
coming up to me doing God knows what,
right.
Just crossing all kinds of fucking lines.
Like literally like you're
a cartoon character.
What made me finally stop was that time
that guy went to take the camera to take
the picture of his girlfriend or wife
and a loaded nine millimeter felon.
You Proud?
Yeah.
And it was right on the ground. And I
should have kicked it away. You know,
all the episodes is Saskia a hot,
shy watched. I did. And I just froze.
I pointed at the gun and I
went, Dude, what the fuck?
And I let them bend down and pick
it up and I just stood there.
I've never felt more white in my life,
you know what I mean?
Just classic Culdesac like, Hey, frank
d I, I believe you dropped your pistol.
Thanks, Bill blows my
fucking brains out. Oh,
you hear that? That's my alarm. I
get up a little early. So anyways,
people,
I think it's a great thing that all of
this stuff is coming out because there's
no way that women should
have to be tolerating this.
They've tolerated it way too long.
But can we stop short here of like,
um,
then trying to literally destroy
everybody around the fucking person,
um, over social media and no
burden of proof whatsoever.
These are like real people that
you're going after. Okay. You know?
Yeah.
These people that are around, these
people that have done horrible things,
they have wives, they have kids, they have
families, they have mortgages. You know,
and just to just fucking just Willy Nilly,
oh,
somebody just said this on Twitter.
It has to be true and just pile on and
blow on the ashes and try to turn it into
fuck a fucking inferno.
MMM.
It's also not right.
Okay.
And,
uh,
I feel really bad for my manager and what
the hell he's going through right now.
I really do.
MMM.
And I'm not going to be one of these
fucking people and I hate how this,
this whole fucking day and it don't
say anything, man. It's not worth it.
Don't say thing.
So I'm just going to lead this guy
who's been a friend to me for fucking 11
years,
guided me through my career.
My career went to the fucking
stratosphere with this gun.
I'm just going to leave them twisting
in the wind. Go Fuck Yourself. They,
Becky's a great guy.
MMM.
Anyways, plowing ahead.
What do we got here? Uh,
but blah, blah, blah. Let's read a little
bit. Uh, no, I, you know what I missed?
I missed the,
I missed a formula one race in it
sounded like it was amazing evidence.
I don't know how Lewis Hamilton ended up,
uh,
starting in last place, but he worked
his way all the way up to first,
which I have never seen somebody
must have crashed because, uh,
I dunno the way Max for staffing
was running during the last race.
Once somebody gets out in front,
you know,
when they're driving
through the clean air,
there was that little thing I know
about aerodynamics and racing.
No one can never catch him,
so,
okay.
They must have had a brilliant strategy
plus like slash else that was plush plus
and slash plash.
Um,
somebody's car must
have broken down or uh,
they must've been an accident or
something. I have no idea. But, uh,
can somebody say, I know you guys
have sent me this link before.
Can somebody try and find a, or
send me the link to where, um,
where I can rewatch the races.
Um,
the replay of him because
Brazil is that brand.
When did you see fucking the Mercedes
Benz team got robbed at gunpoint?
Lewis Hamilton wasn't there and,
but he's quote was basically,
this happens every time we come down here.
How bad is that for tourism in Brazil?
You know what I mean?
Every time we come down here,
the Illuminati sport gets fucking robbed.
Can we do something about security?
Um,
you know, thank God. Like, you know,
if I was like the president of Brazil,
I actually wouldn't be too nervous
because Brazil has arguably the most
beautiful women in the world down there.
You know what I mean?
And that will keep people coming despite
the fact that even the Mercedes Benz
Formula One team gets robbed at gunpoint
and they weren't there on vacation.
They came down there with the entire
sport and somebody still finally got
through. I guess when you got a a pistol,
you don't really need a laminate. The,
uh, can we see her credentials?
Yeah. Yeah. Right here buddy. Okay.
Lewis Hamilton's over there and I believe
he's still has his diamond earring and
have added, um, all right, let's
read a, let's read some, uh,
some advertising here for this week.
Southie. Everybody thought the, um,
everyone at some point has which wish
they could have just have a beer,
wine or liquor delivered while someone
finally decided to do something about it.
Next, please mention all the talking
points below. Introducing Southie. The,
the alcohol delivery APP saucy delivers
your favorite wine be and a right to
you. Do A and no more, no more demand.
It's Uber for alcohol. Now, if you're in
Los Angeles now, if you're in Los Angeles,
San Francisco, Chicago,
San Diego or Sacramento,
you're saucy order will arrive at
your door in 30 minutes or less,
ready to drink for the rest of
us saw, we'll deliver beer, wine,
and liquor to your door in
two days or less. Nationwide,
there are no order minimums, no
delivery fees, no running to the store.
So if you've got a party coming up,
right, your parents are going out of town,
right? You're going to have a Gig,
you're going to have a blowout, right?
You can call these people up.
If you got the saucy APP,
you've got a fully stocked bar right
in your phone. And for a limited time,
you can get $15 off.
Uh,
when you download the saucy APP
and enter the Promo Code Bird,
that saucy app spelled saucy Sau CE.
Why?
And enter Promo Code Burr for $15 off.
Get the saucy app today
and use Promo Code Berm.
Look who's back everybody.
Locals bag Mototo to beyond these Biondi
is why did you lick my neck to do,
to do beyond these me undies?
But I'm a get both of them are guys.
So what the heck? It does a
fucking count if you have a deck.
So if you grab my junk really quick,
you're not going to jail and you're all,
your shit will still be on fucking
Hbo Baba Baba Booboo. All right,
let me tell you about me.
[inaudible] the only underwear.
This is the only one to wear that
makes for an amazing gift. Uh,
feel free to improvise.
Jesus Christ a soft,
that's what they just wrote there.
Talk about why you love me undies.
You know,
I love me on these cause I love
singing this song. That's why.
Plus I evidently, they're
also soft, flexible waistband,
three times softer than cotton.
Cotton just takes a beating during
these, these, these fucking, you know,
these reeds,
they're always getting trashed.
I'm waiting for them to have like
an answer song, you know, uh,
naturally sustainable sourced fiber me
undies has made me undies made underwear.
The perfect Gig gift that
everyone is going to love you for.
It's a great stocking stuffer.
It's a Goddamn holiday miracle this year.
Don't give underwear.
Give me undies this holiday season and
get your exclusive 20% off the softest
underwear and socks you will ever wear.
Free Shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird
that's [inaudible] dot com slash burr.
All right. Dollar Shave Club. Um,
as soon as I heard dollar shave club
had stuff other than their razors,
I was sold. Evidentaly why do they
always try to write what I'm thinking?
All right. I actually think that they're
really smart. Like why stop there?
They get it.
Guys want to shit,
shower and shave and they're
giving them everything to do it.
But with it right at the store,
there are too many options and you can't
tell the difference between any of them.
Then if you have any question,
the clerk usually doesn't
know the difference either
or can't really help you.
Since they are not experts on products,
just like their razors,
everything is super high quality and
left me looking and feeling amazing
evidently from premium ingredients
to sophisticated fence,
sophisticated sense.
You know like before you put it on,
everybody thinks you're a moron.
Then all of a sudden you put on
their fucking body spray though.
Did you go to Grad School?
Dollar Shave Club is changing the game
status set to new members for only $5 to
start a set features there.
Ix executive razor in three trials sized
versions of their most popular products
that help you stay fresh and clean
and your first box, you were deceived.
This shave butter up bodywash
and one wipe Charlies,
but Lipes Oh Chari uh, you will
also receive their executive razor,
which includes their premium, weighty
handle and focus set of cartridges.
By the way,
when you get a razor,
okay,
that as a weighty handle, do not pull it
down and drag it across your face, okay?
You just let it,
you just lightly hold it and you let
gravity pull it down across your face.
That's, that's the way you
do it. All right? Trust me,
if you do it the other way,
you're going to cut your face if
you do it the way I just said,
you're going to get the smoothest shave.
You haven't had new life after the first
box replacement cartridges are sent for
only a few bucks a month.
This offer is exclusively
available@dollarshaveclub.com slash bar.
Uh, that's dollar shave club.com/
[inaudible] and if you want a great gift,
give him dollar Shave Club.
They've got a super simple gift membership
and he giftcards dollar shave club's
high quality products. We'll have you
covered from face cheeks to butt cheeks.
There is no better time to try the club.
Oh and stamp. Stop, calm everybody.
Lastly, but certainly not leastly
stamps saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business.
Uh, you can mail any letter, any package,
just using your computer, a printer
and the mailman comes and picks it up.
Avoid the hassle,
man of the post office and mail
everything from post office, uh,
some postcards to envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes
online with no equipment to lease and no
long term commitments.
Click print mail and you're done.
Unlike the post office
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages
at your own convenience. 24, seven. Um,
it's convenient. It's easy, it's reliable,
it's flexible, it's flexible, right?
Just like that cool chick up the
street that doesn't want to be in a
relationship.
I use stamps.com because anytime I
send out my fucking posters, you know,
and I want to go out there and be a,
have some sexual misconduct with some
women who are far too old to be acting in
that way.
I send them out
through stamps.com do it.
I've actually been telling his story of,
by the letter of the law of something
that happened to me last year,
which was sexual assault,
which was by a woman.
But it's a lady and no one gives a shit.
Um,
I've come out and see my fucking
standup set. There you go.
I'm teasing sexual assault here.
I'm just turning it into a bit.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
and it's a really funny fucking story.
MMM.
But by the letter of the law, it
is sexual assault. Um, you know,
and where's my 15 minutes of fame?
And right now you too can enjoy stamps.com
service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale.
Without a long longterm commitments,
go to stamps.com.
Click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirdthatstamps.com
stamps.com never go to the post office
again. All right. What are we up to here?
All right, 35 minutes. All right,
so the f one of the other, uh,
two reasons why I'm here in
New York. Okay. Reasons. I
did the west side comedy club,
Bam,
a on Saturday night I did a Michael J.
Fox is charity,
the uh,
the Fox Foundation.
I did a benefit for them.
One of the coolest gigs I've
ever got to do in my life. I, uh,
I show up, right? First of all,
it's Michael J. Fox, right?
I mean that guy's comedic timing.
You know,
like when they say somebody has like a
perfect pitch when they go to sing or
whatever. I always felt like, you know,
grew up watching him on family ties and
of course all the back to the future
movies. Um, and I just
piss, timing was just like,
was impeccable. Right. And it
may makes it really, really easy.
But just as a fan of comedy and
everything, I always loved the guy. So I,
I realized I was going to get to meet
him and I show up to the Gig and I'm
always nervous whenever I have to
do a benefit cause it's, you know,
it's a benefit. People going
to be in this, you know,
they're going to be in a certain
mindset or it's just like, you know,
wow, I'm really lucky that
you know, I'm healthy,
I have my family
Blahblahblahblahblah and other,
these other people are going through
this really difficult thing. These are,
there's a sense of like
guilt that you feel, um,
just all of that type.
It just puts the crowd in a certain mood
where then all of a sudden they go from
laughing to everything that
you say is just like, ah,
oh boom.
You know, those are the sounds. I
usually hear it benefits. So I was,
I'm always a little apprehensive and in
my head I'm sitting there going like,
all right,
how can I
navigate this situation?
Cause there's what I want to talk about.
And then there's what I should talk
about just to get through this. Right?
So I show up in the form of the first
people I saw was Eugene Mirman who hadn't
seen in a while and I was so relieved to
see another comedian. I was just like,
God, thank God. So we both would just
sort of laugh and talking about how,
all right, it's a benefit. How
is this? What's going to happen?
How's this one going to go down?
Hopefully this is going to be good.
And as I was talking to him,
I heard this amazing band playing in the
background was like, it sounded so good.
I'm like, is that live? That's unreal.
But we were back in the green room.
I was like, I got to check them
out and raised. I went to go out.
This guy comes walking up,
bye. Goes, hey bill burr. I don't, he
was like, ah, you know, uh, you know,
I've seen your stuff, man. You funny. I
said, oh, thanks a lot. I appreciate it.
I got look at you. You're all
dressed all sharp. I'm like,
are you going up tonight?
Uh, he goes, yeah. I go, what
do you, what do you do? You
meeting? He goes, die. Cause I play a
little guitar. You know, I love musicians.
I'm like, Holy Shit Man. You play in
a band. That's fucking great. Right?
It turned out that guy was Brad Paisley.
I'm old. I don't know who the kids
are. Right. I have no fucking idea.
He went on in the end and was one of the
greatest annotators I've seen in a long
fucking time. Absolutely.
Goes, I play a little
guitar, right? Shreds.
Absolutely shreds on guitar.
Amazing voice.
I said to him after,
cause I felt like an asshole that I didn't
know who he was, but I'm also, I'm old.
You know what I mean? We 50
next year, right? I loved,
and I'm loving turning 50 now. This is
when you start to have excuses. I'm 50,
I don't know things. Um, I
said to him, I said, you know,
I love about you country guys. All
you guys, he can play. You know,
I'm not into all the country music,
but they can,
they can fucking play and they can sing.
And it reminds me of hair metal.
As much as people trashed
me for listening to that,
those guys could play and they could
sing. They could, they could do it live.
We'll do it. Lie, fuck it. Right? So
anyways, I'm hearing all this band.
So I, uh, I go, I gotta go
check these guys out, right?
I have to like the third song or it's,
so I go to walk out there
to see the,
um,
to see the band playing and I looked
at it and I'm looking at the drummer,
this is giant like,
you know,
banquet hall room and I'm just looking
at the drama and I just fucking staring
at him for like five seconds.
It disbelief.
And I look at the woman next to me
who was working for the foundation.
I was like, is that Steve
Jordan? She goes, yeah. He's
like really good. I'm like,
really good. He's one of the greatest
fucking drummers of all time.
This is like a bucket list for me
to ever see this guy play live.
I can't believe I couldn't believe it.
My jaw was on the ground.
Like you got to understand like I, I been
listening to Steve Jordan's since like,
I guess when I first started watching
Letterman and I didn't even realize at
that point that he played on
those blues brothers albums.
Then I discovered those,
I even bought the second blues
brothers album made in America.
Then nobody bought. I have all of
that shit. All of his Keith Richards,
expensive wine. Oh Shit. I watched him
on the leg with the Letterman band. Um,
I go on youtube,
there's a fusion album that he put out
the fuck was the name of
that band that you can't,
I can't find the album anywhere
where he's really young.
Um,
playing on,
on that one a way busier than he
plays on a lot of other stuff. Right.
Through all the John Mayer stuff.
And I was always thinking, okay,
when John Mayer comes to town with his
trio, I'm definitely gonna go see that.
And I'll finally get to see Steve
Jordan playing live, you know,
switching out the snares and all of that,
that whole,
all that whole fits his whole thing that
he does that it's just so incredible.
But every time John
Mayor would come to la,
I would always be on the
road and I'd always miss it.
So I actually got to see him
play. And, um, so anyways,
I'm sitting there and at the
banquet thing and I meet Michael J.
Fox and he's just like the nicest
guy ever. Him and his wife,
just a couple of sweethearts,
you know.
Well just one of those
amazing couples too, you know,
both good looking people and then they,
they formed,
when they get together they form an even
more amazing person, you know? And I'm,
I'm sitting there and like, I'm literally
nervous. Like I'm a brand new comic.
Whenever I get to one of, I do benefits,
I get like that nervous cause like I've,
I've had some that have not gone well.
I've done some Christmas parties.
The reason why I don't do Christmas
parties, I don't do private gigs,
you know,
which are basically rich people
or rich companies or something.
Uh,
get to yeah,
gather and they will literally hire
anyone from like fucking you too,
all the way down to some no name comic.
Like I was back when I used to do those
fucking things and you would go up there
and nobody would know
that there was a show.
And the last one I did.
Yeah.
Like they had me go up.
It was in like a restaurant.
These people had rented out the restaurant
and everybody was eating and talking
and I went up there and I was,
no one was listening and I got defensive.
So my already angry material back then.
It was coming off even angrier and people
just literally stopped eating or just
sort of staring down at their plates.
And um,
I tried every trick that I knew in the
book to turn it around and I couldn't do
it and I just fucking bombed. I
ruined their dinner. I ruined,
they're not at least that part of it.
And I just walked out of there
with my age and at the time,
and God bless him, he had to listen
to me, walked 12 blocks with them,
with absolutely absolute Tourette's,
just going like,
I am never fucking doing one
of those fucking things again.
Who the fuck bring somebody up when
everybody's fucking [inaudible] like I did
that.
I was going,
Casey case him and I suppose to go on
and talk about a fucker dog dying, right.
I went into that mode,
you know, but by the end,
after 12 blocks, I, by the end of it, we
were both laughing and I was just like,
should we given them money back? You
know, that was like, fuck, I feel bad,
but this is a real reason why I was
flipping out. You know, I was embarrassed.
And then I also felt like I
stole money cause I just wasn't,
I wasn't the guy for that Gig.
It should have been like somebody
like a who was happy with themselves.
All right. So anyways, let's
get on with the, uh, not off.
I'll finish telling the
story. So anyways, uh,
fortunately the great Dennis leary was,
was hosting this event and he went up
and immediately turned it into a comedy
show. You know, he was up there doing
what he does and he dropped, you know,
a couple of f bombs.
And then with every joke he told,
I got more and more and more and more
relaxed. And I was like, ah, thank God.
And then, uh, I went
up on stage and I just,
I just fucking went off and,
uh,
told all these, I just, I dunno, I,
I did all those stories telling all those
fucking stories of all the shit that
women have done to me.
And at first people didn't want to
laugh and then they just started laugh.
Cause you know, sexual misconduct,
like I said to a guy, I'm, I'm,
and I'm agreeing with this. It's kind
of funny. It's not right, but it is,
it's funny.
MMM.
And at first they were like,
what the fuck?
And then they just sort of went with it
and then all the rest of my shit just
flowed.
And I ended up having one of my favorite
sets I've had in such a long time.
And then in the end I got to watch,
uh,
this new great musician that I did,
wasn't aware of Brad Paisley
playing with Steve Jordan's band.
And um, and then in the
end they brought Michael J.
Fox out and they all played Johnny be
good. I mean, it was just, it was, I was,
I was just standing there like going, how
the fuck is this? My life was amazing.
Um,
okay.
Then I just end up having,
then it just turned out it was
also the New York comedy festival.
So all these guys were in town.
I got to run into Brant.
Brian Regan who just played
Carnegie Hall hanging out with him.
I just had like the best,
I had the best fucking night and uh,
and the Great New York run here continues
where tomorrow I'm going to be on
inside the NFL. I don't know what I'm
going to be talking about. A God knows.
I haven't watched nearly as much NFL
football is, I would have liked this year.
I just got so busy with the cartoon and
my little acting Gig there. Oh, Bill,
what do you think? You're an actor
now. Every once in a while I am. Um,
all right,
my screen went dark here.
Let's type in the fucking
pass where the password.
Uh, all right, let's, uh, let's
read some of your questions here.
All right. Not enough women or gays at
the cellar table. Oh boy. Here we go.
Oh, read Dick, Billy. All that controversy
in stand standup comedy. He goes,
I was hoping to get your take on an
article I came across on Facebook called
tear down the boys club
that protected Louis Ck.
That's that witch hunt thing that I'm
saying like we had fucking meetings every
week. All right, what are we going to do
here is, hey mom, I'm going to find rrr,
you know, and how everybody
else, the second that God,
evidently everybody else on the other
side, the second that Gawker, uh,
article came out,
you know,
immediately took a criminal justice
course and just became some gum shoe and
went out and bought a giant magnifying
glass and walked around looking for clues.
All right.
It's written by a gay comic who figures
basically going after Louis wasn't
enough. So he is trying to go after his
peers also. Yeah, the witch hunt, uh,
the author cries about a certain table
at the comedy cellar where elite comics
like Chris Rock and Jerry Seinfeld sit.
Um,
okay.
Like when the table came about,
by the way,
Jerry Seinfeld was still doing Seinfeld,
you know what I mean?
I don't know if they actually
had a place called the table. Uh,
when I first started going to the
comedy cellar, there wasn't a table.
Comics just went upstairs and they sat
all over the place. And I am convinced
that the reason why the table was
started was because of Patrice,
because portrays was so loud and so funny
and he was just all over the upstairs.
They were trying to somehow contain
him. He was like, Jordan, you know,
you're not going to stop him.
Let's just see if we can contain them.
So I think they just tried
to get us all in, sit at,
sit it in one seated in one area so
they could at least be like, okay,
sit down and fold your fucking hands
and listen to the teacher. Right.
Um, that's how I remember
it. Anyway, so he goes,
he also has never even tried to perform
it. The Co at the cellar himself,
it's kind of like a fourth grader crying
to the teacher because the cool kids
won't hang out with him. The article
implies that by not speaking up about it,
the seller comics were somehow protecting
Louis even though they were just
rumors until recently.
Also the owner of the cellar,
where are we fucking scream at dark?
Sorry, I'll see you on his salary.
He had some great things
to say in the comments.
Here's the link to the article and go
fuck yourself. Yeah, I read it. And um,
you know, to be honest with
you, considering this guy's
also a fellow comedian,
I feel bad that that was his perception.
I feel filled up yet that that was his
perception of what the table was because
um, you know, the table was like,
uh,
I didn't even know how to explain it.
Like that was something like the level
of pounding that you had to take.
You had to go there and just basically
get ripped to shreds and then what
everybody at the table wanted to do.
And it wasn't even,
it wasn't doing it to just be mean.
It was just,
I don't, it was just this comedian thing.
So you'd sit down and like you already,
you'd sit down with like whatever you
were hung up about with yourself and they
would give another 40 things about you
physically that you didn't even notice
that you should also be self
conscious about. However, in the end,
all they wanted you to do was come
back at them and trash them back.
And if you did urn regardless,
all right.
And there was some epic fucking
back and forths at that table.
You know,
people definitely got
mad sometimes, but, uh,
the table wasn't like what a lot of people
who didn't go to it think it was like
this big bullying thing.
It was also this amazing thing where like,
uh,
I listened to Jewish people
and Arab comics going at it,
talking about the Middle East.
I'd listened to Patrice and, uh,
you know, Manny dorming,
um, their debates,
Colin Quinn was there and
if I remember correctly,
tough crowd came out of those
conversations at the table.
And if you watched tough crowd,
it'd be these comedians talking about
these deep issues trashing each other.
And um, I always felt this,
that the table was inclusive.
As long as you are willing,
you had to,
he had to fucking walk the gauntlet.
You just had to fucking do
and you had to survive it.
MMM.
And then if you did,
you actually became a better comedian
because once you got in at the table,
then there was this thing, you could not
sit at the table. You'd come in and be,
hey,
bill,
come when they wanted you to sit at the
table because they wanted you to trash
you. And then they also wanted you
to trash him back. But you know,
I wasn't even part of the elite crew.
I wasn't funny enough,
I just wasn't like the,
the, the, as far as,
this is just my,
my perception of it was the
table was Patrice Norton Voss,
Keith Robinson,
Collin Quinn,
and later on, Kevin
Hart, Kevin Hart. Right.
And even he was sort of like a,
just like a rookie.
But he also made it so fast. He didn't
have time to fucking stay there. So, um,
those were the,
that was like the Mount Rushmore of the
table and when you showed up and they
will all there and somebody had something
on you like that time, you know,
I for 24 hours said I would do the stand
up on a bus on the weight of a world
series game to get a world series ticket.
And I never even ended up doing the Gig.
I took a headlining set pounding
that is still legendary.
They told the fucking story on
Opie and Anthony,
I believe Kevin Hart and them all told
the story, man, I got fucking destroyed,
destroyed. So this guy like suggesting
that it was all, like everybody was like,
there was this team of people, it
wasn't, it was fucking cannibalistic.
All right. Everything that
they said, an opening,
Anthea was 100% true except for the fact
that I did the Gig because I didn't do
the Gig.
I actually gave the Gig to somebody
else and I w with a vow of silence.
I said,
I will never tell anybody that you did
this gig because I don't want you to go
through what I just went through.
MMM.
I think the guy who did the Gig actually
might've said that he was the one who
did the Gig all these years later.
But I still had them not saying
shit who it was. So anyways,
once you got in at the table,
then you would go downstairs to
go do your set and one night they,
everybody at the table be like, you know
what, we're watching your set tonight.
And you'd be like, Oh fuck.
And you would go downstairs,
you'd go on stage and the crowd couldn't
see all these fucking asshole comics.
I remember they'd all be backlit standing
in the hallway. Patrice is big, dumb,
stupid head.
And you'd have to go up there and like
just commit to your jokes as they were
all standing there
making faces of disgust,
heckling, making noises. And one
time I told a joke and it went good.
And as I was telling the joke, I had the
nerve to actually try to say something.
Image,
Joe and Patrice were just go,
just do that fucking noise and then
they would all crack up laughing.
Then the crowd would laugh like what
the fuck and get a sense of like other
comics are laughing at this guy.
Should we be laughing at him and
not respect him as a human being?
And then you would just start
bombing and I never forget.
I remember Kevin Hart went down stairs
and he went up as a 20 year old comic and
survived it and was barely affected.
I mean,
I know and then looking at all
the stuff that he's doing now,
like you really saw what he was made up.
It was a great thing.
The seller table is not what this person
perceived it to be and I feel bad that
that person, because having a fed Gig,
I'd comic, that would have been great.
They would've been a whole other angle.
It was actually a really inclusive thing.
It's just a lot of people weren't tough
enough to get through it and that's the
truth. And it took me, like I said,
like a half dozen attempts because I was
not a mentally strong person back then.
And um, but if you see what came out
of it, Colin Quinn's tough crowd,
that was one of the most inclusive shows
of all time as far as like, he gave
almost like two and a half generations
of standup comics, a TV credit,
a lot of them, their
first TV credit. Yeah.
MMM.
So I dunno what,
I'm not,
what someone's going to sit down and
watch tough probably who's mainly white
males will blah, blah, blah,
Blah and all that fucking shit.
So I don't know that there's no way
to win this type of stuff, but um,
I can tell you that I, I don't agree
with this person's perception of it,
but I don't have any anger towards that
person for writing that if that's what
they feel, think it was. But, uh,
it's a little melodramatic
burn the table down like this,
these meetings going on and we're all
sitting there trying to hold back his,
his career or whatever.
I mean I don't,
I don't fucking all I remember
as far as like Trans Comics,
I just remembered there was,
I don't know what the proper term was,
but there was a guy who dresses like a
woman who went on stage and went by the
name.
She went by the name of Sharon needles.
Okay.
And she used to go up at the Boston
comedy club and she was fucking hilarious.
And last time I looked her up,
I believe she was still doing shows.
I think she just got out of the standup
scene. But nobody, I don't know.
There's no comics going, girl,
what the fuck is his
fucking person doing here?
Like this all comic, Oh, comedy
is is if you're fucking funny.
Other comics that are going to laugh
and you get their respect and you're in.
MMM.
Uh, you know, everybody has
a different fucking road,
but everybody's just sitting
there going like, just, I
dunno what, what there, it's,
everybody's looking out their
own head and it becomes,
their experience is fact in truth in
anybody else's experience is bullshit or
something like that. So all I'm
doing here is I'm telling my of,
that's how I perceived it. And, um,
I just remember for the longest time,
like we would,
I'm a one night we fucking
were outside the comedy cellar.
We trashed each other for so fucking long.
And it was so god damn funny,
it was so late in the night that this
woman in an apartment above the comedy
cellar poured water down onto us
to get us to shut the fuck up.
And uh, going back, you know,
like a lot of moments like that
in life. I wish I could have, um,
yeah,
I wish I could have realized how
amazing that was during that time.
Cause that's as far as I was
concerned, that table, this,
this table that this guy
wants to burn down that died.
The table died when Manny died
because he was the creator of it.
And, um, he was the,
one of the great conversationalists
that I ever met and he was so God damn
funny.
And um,
okay.
And what I loved about him was he
wasn't a malicious guy as much as I got,
I used to fucking argue with that
guy. You know what I mean? I was just,
I was a young, angry man and I
used to argue with that guy and,
and he was always the next
day it was always over.
And I actually kind of learned from him,
I learned from him and Bobby Kelly how
to squash in argument where like how
you'd be like the next day just,
you know,
cause I didn't grow up
in a family like that.
It was just basically you didn't talk
about it and then you didn't talk for
three days and then fucking
four days later you say, hey,
you see the soldiers giving
was it was good, good.
And then everything was
lingering. Um, those two people,
I learned how to have a functional
end to an argument. So, um, yeah,
I don't know what that shits about,
but it's unfortunate that that person
feels that way about it, but you know,
everybody's entitled to their opinion. All
right. Uh, portrays a Billy Ray, no fun.
Um, after hearing you along with
so many other comics universe,
three Lord Patrice, I finally watched
elephant in the room special. Uh,
within minutes he had me in stitches.
It's so easy to see why he was so
revered within the comedy community.
I know you hold him both as a
comedian, as a person, the person,
and an incredibly high regard.
I would love to hear some
of your insight into him.
I recently heard that he was permanently
banned from performing at the stand in
New York. What was that about? No, he was
never banned from the stand. The stand,
the stand came out or opened right
around when Patrice got sick. Um,
he wasn't banned from there anyways,
really big fan of the show and we'd love
to see come to Australia against soon.
Um, yeah, know Patrice,
Patrice was getting banned
from comedy clubs all the time.
All the time, but he was so fucking
good. They had to let them back get, uh,
it reminds of when I read this,
this miles Davis book,
and he was talking about Charlie Parker
and when he would party to much in pawn
his horn and these clubs
would kick him out,
data eventually have to fucking bring
them back in because he was the best and
Patrice was the best and you know,
as much as he would drive him nuts,
you wanted them around,
you wanted them around you.
It's like the,
like the comedy dropped by 40%,
even with all the other comics still going
there if he wasn't there and just the
fun. And then they also knew that if they
banned him that none of the comics were
going to hang out at the clubs. We were
all going to go to where he was. Um,
yeah. So then they would
let them back into the club.
Okay
then, then they created the table.
That's, that's how I remember it.
That's how I thought that they let's,
we'll have 'em all these fucking lunatics
just have him sit in the back at the
goddamn table. So then we was
sitting down and it's just, you know,
it was just a bunch of
dogs in a fucking pit.
And then that's how the trash in
the trash, it was already happening.
Yeah.
Ama One night,
you know,
after I took the pound in for fucking
the bus Gig that I never even did.
I remember when Bobby
first shaved his head,
he came in and I always respected
him for this. He came in,
he had like a hat on and he sat down
right at the far end of the fat gay Guy
Comic here,
listen to this story.
He didn't shy away from the table.
He fucking walked right in,
sat down,
took his hat off and looked at everybody
like, all right, give it to me.
Let's hear it. And fucking everybody
just, it was like a def jam.
Betty took his hat off and everybody
does. Ma, we went the fuck.
He took this fucking pounding and
everyone was getting him and he was just
sitting there taking it,
laughing and all that type of stuff.
And I actually thought he looked good
with a shaved head. Right. And, um,
what's his face? Uh, I, Oh, who sent it?
I think it was SDSD
finally got him with one.
I think she said, you look like David
Wells. I think that that's what she said.
And everybody fucking died left.
And Bobby literally just
stood up and just walked out.
And I remember thinking like, I didn't
know you could do that. I don't know.
You can block out.
I saw Keith Robinson do that one time too.
We would trash in his clothes,
so fucking bed. It was gay.
And he was trying to fight back
and he was just feeling that way,
was going to crash over him.
He just fucking ran out the door,
got in his car and drove home to Jersey.
We kept texting him and calling him go,
and you can't do that. You can't do that.
He was like, Oh yeah. Well, I just
did stupid. Fucking hung up on us,
laughed and hung up on us.
Um,
oh my God. I remember that
fucking time Patrice. You know,
somehow we found out he, he, he
was home on a Saturday night.
He just took like a night off. And, uh,
Jim Norton fucking came in and said,
you know what Patrice has right now?
He said home on a Saturday night and they
all call them up and on speakerphone,
Patrice just picks up and he's
like, hello. And Jim's like,
what the fuck are you doing home on a
Saturday night? You don't have any gigs?
And Patrice just fucking roared laughing.
And we all over speakerphone,
trashed him.
He was at home getting trashed at the
table. And I just remember him lie.
He loved every fucking second of it.
It was at the tables.
One of the great things ever. So, you
know, don't listen to that guy. All right.
I lied to my girlfriend. Um, all right.
I lied to my girlfriend. Hey Bill.
I really could use some advice.
Right now I'm an 18 year old male and
I have been with this girl for seven
months now. I really care about
her and she makes me truly happy.
About a year ago, I used to smoke
weed and do some drugs, other drugs,
a lot. Uh, I used to smoke about
three or four times a week,
but I quit a little under a year ago.
My girlfriend is really against drug use
and has told me that she would leave me
if I ever did it again.
Well, a couple of months ago,
me and my girl were kind of on a break,
not because we don't want
to be with each other,
but because of some other shit
going on in our lives. All right.
That's pretty vague.
A while we were on this break,
I smoked some weed with a buddy of mine.
Um,
I really regret doing so
because I know how this is,
this means a lot to her.
Um,
she is later asked me when was the last
time I did any drugs and I just lied and
told her the last time was
when I told her I quit.
I can't stop thinking about this and
I feel really bad about lying to her,
but I am afraid she's going to leave me
or stop trusting me if I tell her now,
since I had already lied about
it several times in the past.
Um, all right. What do you do here? Uh,
just to what you wanted to. All right. If
you can't live with it, I would tell her,
if not, I mean, you fucking
smoke. You took a hit off a joint.
If you're not going to, she
really committed and you're
not going to do it again.
Is it really worth putting
you in her through this?
It's kind of hard for me to give you
advice here cause I don't know what you
broke up for. I mean, you did
it while you were broken up.
It's not like you went out
and you bang some other woman,
you just went out and you just tuck your
head and you didn't fucking do it again.
Um, and you know, that's it. But at
the end of the day, you know something,
if you come clean and she's still
breaks up with the over that,
then you know what fucker she gives.
She can't accept you.
It's not like you went out and you
started using heroin and you stole all the
money out of her fucking purse.
She can't handle one hit of a joint
and then you feel bad about it.
And he can't even lie to her about it
without feeling terrible and that you have
to tell her,
but she did you tell her that the reason
why you didn't tell her because you
care about her and you
didn't want to lose her.
If she still leaves you after that,
then you know she was going to
find something. Right. Okay.
Jim Girl, uh, you know something. I don't
know if I have time to read all of these.
I, I gotta I gotta fucking get
Outta here. Here. Oh, do you? Okay.
This is the worst thing ever.
I'm going to try to read this quickly.
I already read bad when I'm reading
at a normal pace here. Hey, Billy,
cue ball. A couple of months back,
I started going to another gym,
a town over for a change of scenery.
Uh,
after a couple of weeks I've run
into this tall athletic girl.
She didn't talk to anyone and had that,
I'm not trying to talk to anyone.
Look going on because of this,
me and virtually.
Okay.
Because of what?
Because of this and me virtually never
cold approaching a girl before I left her
alone over the next few weeks.
I noticed she would be in my area a lot.
And when moving between exercises,
we would cross paths a lot. Uh,
sounds like you're doing that fucking
whatever that workout is. Crossfit. Well,
you got to run down the street. You know,
look at us, everybody, we're working out.
Hey, look at us, you know,
leaving your gym and running around and
fucking seven 11 parking lot in coming
back. We get it. You're working
out. Jesus Christ. All right.
Over the next few weeks I noticed she
would be in my area a lot and when,
all right, I already said that. Okay.
Uh, we cross path. All right. So,
um, I said fuck it. And
started talking to her.
We had a couple of good compost and I
eventually got a number. Look at you.
You're in the game.
We didn't text much,
which is fine because I've learned that
texting should be mainly for planning
meetups.
I still try to a couple of texts
Convault's for some rapport since uh,
I'd only seen it one to three times
a week, sometimes just in passing.
Now the issue is every time I messaged
her, she randomly stops messaging.
No, probably cause you're
bugging her at that point,
no matter how good the conversation
was going or she's busy. Uh,
I didn't see her for a week before I left
for vacation for another two weeks and
no contact.
It's been a week since I've been back
and I haven't seen her in the gym.
Was marginally interested.
Well she marginally interested or
did I not come on strong enough?
Should I text her again? Oh, just
move on and wait til I see her again.
Well, if you're still into
or just Texas, just say, Hey,
I haven't seen yet the gym and with
the voice, the harm in that, you know,
in this day and age,
you know,
make sure there's a lawyer there when
you're doing that because who knows with
the, uh, the, the, what the next
fucking thing is going to be.
Um, yeah, I would just, I
would text her and just say,
hey, you know, back, you know,
would you like to go out sometime?
Gives a fuck,
fuck her and our cold fucking vibe.
Just say what you want to do.
Anything she wants to do it. Go do it. If
she doesn't move on, that's it. Easy one.
All right. But I wouldn't question
yourself, you know, fuck all that.
Don't be in your head.
Um,
be like Jon Favreau in swingers. You
know, that's what I always think.
Just never get into that fucking
mode. Just, uh, you know,
it's normal to be nervous. Both men and
women when you're dating or whatever,
men and men, women and women,
everybody included. Um,
whenever you get into that,
I would say don't ever send a text when
you were in that mode. I would sit down,
relax, and just think, what do I want?
I want to go on a date with this
person. Well, that's what you ask them.
I would love to take you out sometime.
See me a minute.
I'd love to take you out
sometime. Right? That's it.
What's she going to say?
How dare you fucking ask me out.
She's either going to say yes or no. Okay.
And if she says no, who gives a fuck?
You don't have any regret your asked,
but if you don't ask,
then you got to be like, all
right, for some gone wrong.
This is the last one and I'm done.
I recently visited my friend at his big
time college for his schools. Right.
School rivalry weekend.
Um, I'm going big. Damn.
That's what they said when I went to
Notre Dame versus a USC and they were like
big time college football.
Uh, speaking of, uh,
Notre Dame got a big Tam ass
kicking against Miami. Holy Shit.
The convicts kicking the
shit out of the fucking,
I like are they still called the
Catholics and not the pedophiles?
You know what I mean? I
mean, not everybody at the
University of Miami, you know,
has gone to jail or been arrested.
Okay.
But if you're going to call him
convicts and we got damaged,
but you gotta go pedophile
with Notre Dame. Right. Um,
it was a great tam and
his school was one school,
one in at the last second and at the
last second. So the atmosphere is crazy.
Later that night,
I attended a party at the fraternity.
He is a member of a anyway,
wage.
We meet these two girls and decided to
tell him we were actually real real life
brothers and we somehow tricked slash
convinced these girls into having a
foursome.
How do you tell them that you're
related and that they want to do it?
Yeah.
Tricked is a very dangerous world
word to use right now, buddy.
Uh, all right, we all go into this room.
What do you mean trick? What do you
do? Did you do the old quarter? Hey,
we'll make a quarter disappear. Hey,
where's the quarter as a blind you here?
Here's my Dick.
Uh,
we all go into his room and start
hooking up and since he had a large bed,
we had girls on it and we're
banging them side by side,
doggy style after what seemed like a
while, but was probably six minutes.
I unfortunately released
my champagne and victory.
So now it's my buddy and both the girls
in the bed and I'm just in the corner of
the room.
I really wanted to come back in there,
but I knew it would take a little
bit of time to get back up.
So I decided to look for something
to use to start jerking off. Oh.
I found out where it turned out to be my
buddy's context solution and applied it
and started tugging. After a
few minutes, Olympic tugging,
I started to feel movement and
thought I'd be back in the game. Soup.
You're like an injured player that went
out for a play at that ball moment,
my buddy and the two chicks,
so he was nailing turn around and
face me and catch me jerking off.
From their perspective. They
think of jerking off to them. Oh,
now when in reality I'm jerking
is so I can bang the second girl,
one girl sort of freaks out.
Okay.
I love that she freaks out if they have
to fucking thinking that she's having a
fucking force him with two brothers.
One girl sort of freaks out and my buddy
screams, what the hell are you doing?
Okay.
At that point I didn't know what to say.
So I ran out of the room naked and
just stood outside the door until they
finished.
Eventually the girls left and my buddies
let my buddy let me back into the room
where he proceeded to ask why I
was jerking off to him. Oh No.
He goes,
I tried to plead my case and give
rash and give a rational explanation.
But he's continuing to be persistent that
I was jerking off to him and now he's
being extremely distant from me and
is told all of our friends who have
constantly been berating me for jerking
off while my buddy bank two chicks.
Do you have any advice on how I can
somehow spin this story? I mean,
at the end of the day I did
get laid to, um, all right,
here's what's hilarious about on it
that the woman gets offended. Like,
what are you doing? It's
like, what are you doing?
You're having like a fucking force
them with two people that you think are
related. Uh, and secondly,
I don't know how guys do that.
I don't know how you could bang a
woman with your buddy next to you. Oh,
so banging,
you know what I mean?
Like how do you block out the sound of
your friend? Like, Eh, right next to you.
I mean,
do you look at each other at any point
and like how do you not start fucking
laughing? I, I don't, I've
never understood that. Uh,
yeah, you probably should
have gone into the bathroom.
You probably shouldn't have
been looking at them. I mean,
do what you have here is
a fucking hilarious story.
And I, you know, in the
spirit of the table.
Yeah.
All right. When your friends are
giving you shit, I would just laugh.
You just have to learn to laugh at
yourself and just be like, I swear to God,
I was trying to get back
in the fucking game.
Just tell the story the way you just
told it to me and think that it's fucking
hilarious that this dude thinks
she would jerk it off to him.
I would just laugh it off. Um, which
is how you get out of most shit.
You know,
it's how Donald Trump became president.
He just, it's probably a bad guy to bring
up who's out there grabbing pussies.
It'd be like you said all
this shit about women. No, I,
I said it about Rosie O'donnell.
Ah,
well you said about other women too and
he's like, yeah, you probably right.
It ends it, it's when you keep fighting
it. I would just fucking laugh it off.
I know it's tough at your age,
but listen dude,
if you have it in you to fucking fuck
a woman right next to your friend,
if you, if you have the focus to do that,
I think he can get through this. Um,
but dude, you got it. One hell of a
goddamn story. That's a great story. Um,
so anyways, all right,
that's it. I have to,
I've got to get on with my day
here and thanks to everybody, uh,
who's listened to the podcast.
Thanks to the Fox Foundation,
the west side comedy club.
Please go.
Please go out to the kind of club and
thanks to everybody on front runner, uh,
that, let me have a quick little part in
that thing. I had such a great time. Oh,
and by the way, guess what's out daddy's
home part too. I was in part one.
You got his part too, I heard
is even better. Joe Barton,
Nick Rosebowl tailgate legend told me
he went to go see, they said, dude,
I fucking laughed out loud like 25 times.
Comedians don't laugh out loud ever.
It's one of the, one of
the fucking, I dunno,
it's one of the prices you pay as
a comedian. You stopped laughing.
You just start going, oh, that
was funny. But you never laugh.
You never laugh again. So definitely
go check that out. And uh, who knows?
Who knows? Maybe you'll see a
familiar face and there, all right,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.